[Applause]
foreign
happy Monday everybody I'm back you
lucky people I'm back
yeah I took a week off I took a week off
now that helps me relax like a few days
of court ordered community service
but you know what didn't take a day off
or a week off trans it's everywhere you
notice that everywhere and man is it
starting to get boring I missed the good
old days when the man who dressed as
women were real men
laughs
we called them crossdressers
or in some case Dad
but now they're just screaming stupid
babies right here's woman swimmer Riley
Gaines an actual woman at SF State being
attacked by a morose mob
ility
ah that was fun
lovely people Riley spoke out because
she feared men invading her private
spaces and attacking her waiter prove
her wrong fellas
so what was Riley's crime defending
female athletes who got shoved aside by
Leah Thomas a biological male whose
shoulders are wider than Joy behar's ass
[Laughter]
a plotter butt
now the school actually released a
statement praising the rioters for their
bravery so men claiming to be gals gang
up on a woman who dared to disagree with
them and the school sides with the mob
not her if that's what the modern left
considers feminism I might start wearing
a bra again Gloria Steinem must be
rolling in her grave but I think she's
alive
there was another riot in the Tennessee
House of reps last week where two Dems
were expelled for their role in a
chaotic gun control protest inside the
Capitol Building remember when dams
didn't like riots in government
buildings these people are more full
than my hamster cage after taco Tuesdays
that's weird because I don't even have a
hamster
and why did those idiots uh take part in
that Riot because trans massacred six
people including three children but as
if On Cue Dems made themselves the
victims and then of course called
everyone a racist so now you got the
Press more outraged over the Injustice
to these Spotlight Chasers than actual
victims and that brings us to another
performance artist of the moment Peewee
her him
AKA Dylan Mulvaney the new spokesperson
Bud Light hopes will reach consumers who
never drink their product otherwise
known as fans of decent beer
Nike Bud Light Kate Spade are a few
Brands paying the spinstrol to do this
girls are dumb Act
I mean I understand Bud Light because if
a guy drinks that beer he's half a woman
already
[Laughter]
I drink it
and is cloying Audrey Hepburn ripoff
happens to be paying off she's even
selling sports bras to women which seems
unfair to women I mean it's a weird
Choice a guy to sell bras it's like
hiring Brian stelter is a model for
Men's Health
it's like hiring Don Lemon for Tampax
for women not past their Prime
thank you
it's it's as bad as hiring the view for
Victoria's Secrets
[Laughter]
or Kevin Spacey for the Boy Scouts
seriously imagine you're white
pretending to be a black person in order
to attract them to your product I'm
sorry Rachel told us all I don't think
you'll be picking up endorsement deals
like the others but what a win for Nike
someone who identifies as a woman
selling shoes made by people who
identify as children
but you got to ask why is this happening
all at once way out of proportion to the
percentage of trans in the general
population it's like you're watching a
civil rights movement at a thousand
times the speed but minus the Civil part
one of the reasons the corporate
equality index it's a social credit
score given to businesses by the Human
Rights Campaign an lgbtq lobbying group
they keep track of woke brownie points
and issue report cards and criteria like
supporting an inclusive culture and
trans restroom policies
watch this Bud Light exec throw her
consumers Under The Keg this brand is in
Decline it's been
drinkers to come and drink this brand
there will be no future for Bud Lights
like we need to evolve and Elevate what
does evolve and elevate mean it means
inclusivity Bud Light had been kind of a
brand of
Friday kind of out of touch humor and it
was really important that we had another
approach
yeah
so apparently not enough men are
drinking Bud Light and instead of maybe
asking why this bozo goes woke and why
because she's lucky her metrics of
success aren't about making a profit
instead it's performance as in
pretending acting signaling faking it
she may have killed their brand but
maybe that's the point so this is really
a performance movement which is what all
wokism is of course nobody believes a
man can become a woman just by declaring
it so any more than believing can raise
my height to six foot five
from six foot two right correct thank
you
but you don't have to believe in
anything just say it so and if people
don't applaud With Tears in their eyes
and they're all bigots oh I got tears in
my eyes all right from laughing at men
who look like linebackers wearing
backless sundresses
and that's the other point fact is only
a few people can pull off this trick all
the wannabe Dylan Mulvaney's on Tick
Tock aren't fortunate enough to be
adopted by corporations or have all this
money for surgery so they dye their hair
purple throw on a dress and say I'm a
woman if only it were that easy
[Applause]
mouth was once pulled over for speeding
most of the trucks True Crime podcast
Emily campagno
this anchor can weigh me down whenever
he wants co-host of America's Newsroom
Bill hammer
first stunt double is made entirely of
pipe cleaners Fox News contributor
tattoo
and his tattoo artist buys ink in bulk
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Bill welcome to the show thank you
welcome back we missed you oh did you
really yeah yeah I didn't miss you I
think you were gone right yeah I was no
I was in your neighborhood the entire
time I was out in front of your
apartment I was standing there sure yeah
oh man that's how we know you aren't six
two
he looked out his window he didn't see
anything
you were there like this and he's on the
first floor
you know um
I'm not that I'm not that interested in
the whole and what trance is I'm
interested in the explosiveness of this
movement I've never seen anything like
move like this like in a contagion form
of way yeah it's taken off I mean again
my objective here Greg is to get out of
here without getting in trouble yes
um so let me see if I can do that all
right have you had Bud Light lately no
in a can no this is glorified water man
yeah I mean I gotta tell you that woman
doing marketing at Bud Light is catching
more heat than my good friend Don Lemon
yeah for the moment Grant it has Greg
um
I don't know where it goes I think some
people will view this as coming out of
nowhere perhaps but suddenly it is
everywhere and I think you have to ask
yourself why and it's been embraced by
this Administration and let's just see
let's see how it's incorporated into I
like that hand movement into Americans
to say you know I was thinking about
trying to get him in trouble if
like Leah Thomas was in the pool right
yeah and I got a lot of attention uh
some people said it was okay some people
did not I think Riley Gaines has shown a
lot of guts a lot of people are trying
to run her down the other day at that
that event but a week ago at the NCAA
women's basketball finals 10 million
Americans watch this game they have
never had viewership like this before
and these were great players and this is
basketball this is basketball
as far as I could tell they were all
women and if you had a transgender
Athlete on that floor then I I think we
would have seen the difference between
everything that was going on there and
it would have been a disadvantage to
people from Iowa or LSU have put in 20
years of their life trying to get there
you go well there you've navigated that
quite sprightly he was like one of those
tightrope walks he was like a flying
wallinda trying to get through there
Emily you know the woman said her brand
is too fratty isn't that kind of a
saying to White malish isn't she a
racist
your word's not mine uh yeah I I think
what's so concerning to me about this is
that in this explosive movement now it's
had real world consequences that are way
deeper than we can imagine than we can
imagine I used to think that it was just
about social media and you know youth
groups at college with signs and walking
out at high schools and whatnot like ah
don't grow out of it but that corporate
equality index that you mentioned that's
a significant anvil on our corporate
America that report card matters and it
matters in a horrifying way which not
only
um can they elective electively and
subjectively award okay so here's your
20 points because you have a policy
about your bathroom here's a negative
amount of points because you donated to
let's say maybe a lobbyist that said
that oh maybe I want parental permission
or guidance or input before surgical
transformation under the age of 10. they
have real world consequences because the
three largest investment firms go by
that the top 15 of the top 20 uh Fortune
100 companies they were all 100 ranked
here so it's also concerning because it
flies in the face usually of who the
duty is of these corporations so you
would think all right duty to the to the
shareholders to the taxpayers you know
we want to make everyone money right
isn't that the point but here instead
they're saying no no I have to make sure
that I hire someone that has checked all
these boxes right and I post a sign up
and I give everyone the day off if
they're feeling upset and that's why
Banks fail yeah you know what they went
from their duty to just Duty yeah cat
you know what I'm going to ask you
I really never do
guys selling sports bras Dylan Mulvaney
selling sports bras we have a similar
body
so I can't get that mad because maybe
I'll model bras or something
first of all
I'm Not Gonna Knock fratty like I'm so
fratty myself that yeah I drink Bud
Light and I refer to it as a crispy boy
it's crispy it's boy you get it yeah uh
but so Friday's not a bad thing but
Dylan Mulvaney specifically I mean I'd
be very uncomfortable around somebody
who just has anybody who has that
resting smile face going on right
how do you like behave like what if
you're having a bad day you know it's
just it's just the one note
are you okay I'm uncomfortable yeah
I'm extremely uncomfortable I just don't
know how it's not just trans it's this
one specific person that is the face of
literally everything everything yeah and
I'm the face of nothing I know that's
the Justice she took your job why who
like who said I drink Bud Light yeah I
mean listen to me yeah
all right Tyrus
when will we see the first trans
wrestler who've been there done that
yeah
because they can't it's not I mean we
have we've had it in this in the in the
sport of wrestling for ever because
there's no unfair Advantage yeah someone
else decides what happens so uh so in
that aspect the wrestling's fine yeah
it's not a big deal I'm not uh if
wrestling became a street fight then yes
I would have more belts
um
but I I think all jokes aside the the
ugliness of this is you mentioned Rachel
dolezon right who
wanted to live her life as a black woman
and she was doing what working to enrich
and help black kids get into school
and everyone was attacking her for
stealing her right a culture yeah even
though she was doing and myself yeah I
made jokes but she was doing things to
try to help the group that she wanted to
imitate
how many times did you see her on TV go
yeah girl what uh-huh I Got a Baby Daddy
huh yeah never did that once
and if she did would be saying what she
was wearing black face yeah she was
being racist
Devon's wearing Woman face he's parading
around like the dumbest woman in the
world you guys didn't know what happens
in March yes that's right
that's women women are bubbly and dumb
and cry and make faces that's black face
but it's Woman face and that used to be
not okay now you got the same thing
where now men who dress as women can
chase a woman down the hall threaten to
beat her up demand that she gives them
money to let her go and they're
applauded for it
so when does this stop next time there's
domestic violence a woman has the holy
live beat out of her but the man says he
identifies as a woman and then we don't
really know what a woman is anymore so
it was just a fair fight between two
people
so we need to start it's less a joke and
more of an attack on women and in a very
blatant attack by and to Emily's point
this Equity thing these companies that
push this and the three big ones that's
why they have the same person because
it's all the same people
and then they put their people in the
jobs that make the decisions so that
horrible speech that all of us are
Dumber fratty it's not even a word like
she just says things because she was put
in a position she's not qualified for
she walked into the first meeting and
couldn't figure out one thing on the
board so said nope it's not working it's
not working these numbers aren't right
we have to make we have to bring more in
they put there is they they're getting
in the top seats without the without the
experience or anything and their
Prejudice and they're moving we're
watching a corporate overtake but here's
the beautiful thing don't buy them
turn it off don't buy it
[Applause]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else